[Laughter]  well mrs. Vale another rooster in the  henhouse take thy beak rooks way nespa  most of the time let me taper this guy I  know jack mean kid bad seed hurt people  I like him already you know the problem  was he got sloppy you know crazy he  started to lose it  get a head full of bad wiring I guess  couldn't keep it straight up here he was  the kind of guy couldn't you the train  till it was two feet from  you know what happened to this guy Jack  made mistakes  tell me something my friend never dance  with the devil in the pale moonlight  what I always ask that of all my Brae I  just like the sound of it never rub  another man's rhubarb away I'll need a  moment alone boys I'm only laughing on  the outside my smile is just skin deep  if you could see inside cry you might  join me for a week  [Music]  you